kelly what was going on in your life
when you decided to
live in california you left was it texas
yeah i grew up in the panhandle of texas
and i had
you know just turned 18 i had graduated
high school and
usc had accepted me to their theater
program so i was this
young girl with big hair and big ideas
moving out
from west texas to go to the big city
and
um you know i had grown up doing
a speech in theater in high school and i
knew that in some capacity i wanted to
be in the entertainment industry so
when usc started to recruit me my
sophomore year of high school i was you
know about 15.
i saw that as my opportunity i applied
to a bunch of other
schools but usc was the one that i
wanted
to go to and i knew it there was no way
that my
mom could have afforded my my education
there so i made sure that i worked
really hard
in school and i graduated at the top of
my class and i got grants and
scholarships
and they covered most of my tuition for
the fourth
the four years that i was there i did
have to work i worked a 40-hour a week
job when i was at usc
but that's that's how i got my start i
you know i moved out here with
um less than 1300 bucks in my pocket and
just
a bunch of hopes and dreams and you know
years and years later some of them are
are starting to come true and i'm sorry
you drove out here
i drove out here how long did it take um
it took a couple of days you know
i i had a i i i remember having all of
these like you know
cds from the late 90s like you know a
lot is more set and i kind of stopped
blasting
i was a big toriyamos fan but that's you
know sort of my
that was my road trip and music but uh
yeah and i was the only person
you know in my dorm with a car so i made
a lot of friends my freshman year
what were you thinking about on that
two-day road trip
of course you were obeying the speed
laws i'm sure sure 18.
yeah absolutely um
no i was thinking you know i should have
been really scared
but i was so excited i was just so
excited because i was leaving
i knew i was leaving this part of my
life behind and i knew
i mean i don't think that there are many
people
that can be so certain about what they
want to do with their lives
and and that's what's kept me in this
industry for as long as i have because
i've known for so long that this is what
i wanted
you know i'm not as successful as i want
to be right now
but i know that one day if i keep
working you know it will happen
um so i was thinking on that drive out
there that you know this is this is the
start this is the start of my life
and what was the first like destination
do you actually
drove to the usc campus no actually i
i stayed with a friend of mine in the
santa barbara area at first because
i left before school started i literally
could not wait to
take it out to california so i stayed
with a friend
on the on the west coast for a bit and
for a good
you know five six weeks before school
started i had
the first summer freedom that i think
you know i'd ever had my life i was 18
and i was just you know able to go up
and down the coast
i did have to go to campus a couple
times on one occasion i was trying
to figure out something with the
financial aid office and this is
this is mortifying but i didn't know how
to parallel park a car
oh you don't need to do that in west
texas um so i was
on the campus and this you know i was
trying to park my my
lovely pos car um and this officer
knocked on my window and i rolled it
down and i'm like oh my god i'm in
trouble i'm in trouble he's like
do you want me to just do that for you
so
i was like okay so he just he parked my
car for me it was very nice
very nice wow
clearly i needed the help
how does i'm sorry forgive me how how
does usc recruit people like were you
already applying to the program or
no what had happened is i was doing
speech and theater competitions
so texas is like a 4a 5a school it's
just it's just the way the districts are
broken up
so you do these competitions in speech
and theater you can do
prose and poetry you can do dramatic
interpretation
it's actually called the nfl's the
national forensics leagues
is part of who it's hosted by and i
remember when we were all competing in
high school we were told you know brad
pitt was in the nfl so this was you know
this was a big thing for
you know for us and i actually i
remember my my senior year i went to
nationals and josh gad
had made it into the finals and of
course you know we all watched him and
it was amazing and then you know years
later he's josh gad
but that was my first introduction to
him so a lot of people
uh you know who got their start
especially on the acting side of things
that's
that's how they they got into it so but
you know the recruiters from usc they
they you know all of the colleges kind
of follow the people that track in the
tournaments and that's how my
my start happened and then once you were
up and running
uh you know you had your job you were
going to classes
how are you acclimating to the
difference of
texas i forgive me i've only been
through on the air
via the airport but you know i realize
it's a different you know there's
there's
southern charm there's manners there's
things that maybe
la doesn't have and maybe on the
opposite
how are you acclimating to that you know
it was very funny i grew up actually
a left-handed vegetarian democrat so
i kind of acclimated very quickly to the
california climate
um i'm no longer a vegetarian but i
i fit in pretty quickly you know
certainly
dealing with uh you know the the culture
shock you know when you're 18
i think it i think it's better to do
something like that when you're younger
i think you're more open to taking
risks than you would be say if you were
were older like
i i'm very glad that i i made the move
to go when i did
when i was 18 because had i been you
know in my late 20s or my 30s and
established somewhere else i might have
been
too afraid to to let go and and try
something new
so you were raised in texas are there
any texan sayings that you kind of live
your life by i know it seems like
there's a lot of everything's bigger in
texas they have just
different interesting different
interesting sayings
i think one of the funniest ones that
you can
get away with saying and i think that
you know the jokes kind of out on this
one is
bless your heart you know that's just
something that you say when
you know you're being polite but really
it's casting a lot of shade at somebody
um i think another funny you know saying
from the south is
uh jumpier than a fart and a griddle oh
and that means that you're nervous
so i've used that on occasion and people
have looked at me like
what are you talking about um but no i
find
you know there's one of the screenplays
that i that i wrote the one that
actually
launched my my career with my agents and
my manager and you know won
the ucla screenwriting competition um
it's it's inspired by my grandmother and
it's it's called the baltimore school of
charm
it's about a woman in the 1950s who
murders her abusive husband and goes on
the run by pretending to be an east
coast debutant
and she hides out and she pretends to
affect these manners from the
you know emily post's book etiquette
so she she that's how she disguises
herself so
for me growing up with that sort of you
know grace and charm was something that
my grandmother
instilled in me from a very young age um
you know she my grandmother didn't
murder my grandfather
but she did get out of a really bad
situation and she
you know went off and you know did her
own thing and she came back years later
and
this is a woman who hadn't graduated
high school um
you know she she wasn't formally
educated but somehow she started
coaching women through them as texas
pageants
and you know i remember being a child
and she would teach me and my sister how
to you know walk with books on our heads
and
how to properly get out of a car and how
to pump gas and this is you know you
pump gas you put your doe skin gloves on
because you don't want to get your hands
dirty so there was this sort of
genteel nature about her that i really
wanted to capture
in this character millie and
you know they always say write the thing
that you're afraid of and i was i was
afraid to tell the story um
because it does deal with a lot of
things it deals with you know domestic
violence
and you know getting out of that
situation and it's it's not pretty i
mean it's
it's she she kills her husband in the
narrative um
but i wanted it to have this underlying
element of grace
and the way that i incorporated that was
to sort of make the text
from emily post's book which is the
authority
on on etiquette the underlying theme
i know you've written you've written
scripts you have plays
stage plays you're working on you also
have two children's books
so i'm wondering did you have a parent
or grandparent that would like sit you
down and read to you and that's for your
love
of stories yeah absolutely i i mean i
have one
children's book that's published right
now with scholastic so there are more in
the works i was actually emailing with
my editor today
oh oh i thought you had two okay maybe
not i will have
the ether yeah i will
my grandmother was sort of the impetus
for for a lot of the things
that i have carried through me with my
childhood
to an adult i didn't necessarily have a
harmonious environment
growing up so she was this sort of
escape for me
and i would spend weekends at her house
and she would
always you know come up with the most
amazing games and she had books i mean
this is this is pre
video games and you know technology and
things like that so we would play
with board games and books and she would
constantly read to me
constantly read to me um she would
constantly encourage me to write
and you know act things out and um
she actually was the inspiration for my
first children's book too
so um the the book is called sleepy toes
and it's for kids now the way that i the
way that i
started to to write this and how this
came to be is
um when i turned 30 i was in a place
where i was very
very unhappy with my life um and i
decided to do something about it
so i created something called a fuck-it
list and i hope i can say that
yeah you can okay so i created i created
my pocket list
and that was basically it was like a
bucket list
and yes there's a script about this too
so
um but the [ __ ] it list was
the things that i was afraid to do in my
life and i just thought you know what
i'm dirty i
i don't have the luxury of letting fear
be the deciding factor for what i want
to do anymore so
i did things like i took myself to new
york i went on a trip to asia
i you know lost a bunch of weight and i
took my hand at writing
a children's book and it was called uh
your feet are getting sleepy
and i had illustrated it myself and i
wrote it and i self-published it
my background isn't in you know
marketing and creative direction so i
packaged this whole thing
um i did an audio recording you know i
had i hired a friend of mine from the
groundlings to to
you know narrate it and we i hired a
musician to score it you know it had
like a six minute lullaby afterwards
like to play you know kids to sleep and
i put all these materials together and i
sent it out to every single publisher
that i could
you know think to send it to you know
anybody that was
you know open to queries and i got very
close with one publisher but they
ultimately passed so i was like all
right well this was a very expensive
experiment and four years later
i get a phone call from a woman at
scholastic
and she says hi you know my name is
so-and-so um i
received your submission all these years
ago and my boss no longer runs this
department i do
and i was calling to see if you would be
interested in publishing with us
wow this is four years after i had you
know self-published and submitted
it so anybody that says self-publishing
doesn't lead to
you know the results at some point i i
they're not in there's not all instances
where that's applicable but this you
know
from the time that i made myself do it
and got it out there
it unagented the very first thing that i
send out there
gets bought by the world's largest
publisher
four years later four years later
unbelievable like unbelievable
and that sort of kick-started everything
else
and this book sleepy toes that's what it
became
but my grandmother used to do this thing
with me you know to get me to sleep at
night you should go your feet are
getting sleepy
very very sleepy and she'd work her way
up you know your body until you'd
eventually drift off and fall asleep so
i this is what i put together into this
book and
my editor saw the value in it and
over 50 000 copies have been sold now um
it's yeah it's it's act it's done really
really well um and that's you know that
opened up the door to so many other
things so
i i think that you know it was it was
the heart that went into the story
that that propelled it forward so it's
it's one thing to just
you know write something i mean and
writing kids books is hard it's it's
harder than writing screenplays believe
it or not
yeah um you know the book is only about
30 pages long
but you know from the time that it got
acquired to the time that we finished
the revisions
to the time it got published that was
a six and a half year stretch we were i
mean we worked on revisions for the text
for this for
for months um but yeah so that's
and someone else did the illustrations
this amazing illustrator named corey
doorfeld
uh did the the illustrations typically
if you're
and this is this is advice because i get
asked this all the time as a children's
book author
do you send illustrations should you pay
someone to illustrate your stuff for you
no the answer is no if you are not
inherently an illustrator author
don't pay for someone to do it and and
don't try to do it yourself because
when your publisher actually does take
your book they will
match you with somebody so they they're
the ones that take care of that but if
you are an illustrator author which is a
very
that's a hot commodity so if you have
that talent then
by all means market that out but not if
you're just a writer
and so the second book that you're
working on is what
stage is that in right now there's a
there's a couple oh there's a couple
okay
there's a couple so so there's a lot of
them that are just in log line format
there are some that have been you know
drafted out into the first iterations
um there's they're in all the various
phases it would be it would be unfair
for me to pinpoint something right now
but definitely
one thing that i always try to do for
myself is when i get an idea i write it
down
like even if it's a silly idea write it
down because you never know when you're
going to need to come back to it and
that's kind of where i found myself at
right now so
and where do you keep these ideas are
they like in a little book or a computer
um so i typically put them in a google
sheet so i will write everything in
a google sheet so it's accessible no
matter where i'm at um this is another
thing that i always
make sure that i have all of my ideas
pitches log lines
they need to be accessible at any point
in time because if you you don't you
never know when you're going to be asked
to pitch
i was attending an event we
my other project daruma has been
we've started partnering with
organizations like the reeve foundation
and respectability
and the rudderman foundation have you
know they've taken notice because this
features two disabled lead actors but
the movie's not about their disability
we were invited to attend a roundtable
event just
just to be there you know just as a
special guest but this was an event that
the respectability
people had put on to help their
you know people people with actual
disabilities in the industry to try to
get work and learn what to do
and i'm sitting there in the lobby and
you know i'm waiting for this event to
start and this gentleman comes up to me
and he starts talking
i had no idea that it was the featured
speaker
so he starts asking me you know what
what are you doing here you know
why are you here and i told him about
our project and he was like let me see
let me see and had i not had it on me
i would have missed an opportunity so
always be prepared always be prepared to
have your ideas
accessible and also too you never know
like always be open to i know in la
it's easy to get closed off because we
don't know
what the person's agenda is but you just
never know what
someone could actually might be harmless
you know and that sounds like
something great yeah i mean it's it's
not to say you know have every
interaction and looking at
what can what can that person do for me
but certainly be open and respectful
to talking to people um it's
very hard if you're shy and i mean i'm
not i'm not inherently an outgoing
person
that's something that i've had to work
on um you know
when you're meeting with different
development execs
one of the things that they ask you to
do is you know to
you know tell me about yourself that's
that's a huge question
that you get asked all the time what
they're
doing is they're trying to figure out is
this somebody that we can put in a room
with the director can i put my producers
with them
can i can this person be socially
competent in that environment or am i
going to regret this hiring decision
so this is this is the first phase of
your interview and
you know i learned this from from when i
was acting as well
your audition doesn't start when you get
in the room your audition starts the
minute you get out of the car
because you don't know who you're
talking to you don't know if you bump
into somebody you don't know
the receptionist you know 20 you know 15
years later whatever maybe maybe they
turn into something and if you have a
negative interaction
it's going to stick with somebody so
positive action interactions can be
neutral but negative
interactions you will have a very hard
time recovering from that
sure when they ask you tell me about
yourself
how much time is appropriate
some people could go on forever others
be very quick
i think it's really about reading the
room my first general lasted about 45
minutes which is pretty good
when you when you read the room um you
know if you're in there for
25 minutes or under you didn't
necessarily have the best meeting
because it's they're eager to to get on
to the next thing so
um if your meetings go for an hour or
more you're
you've had a good interaction i mean
obviously be respectful of their time
um i met with an executive once who an
hour into our meeting her assistant
knocked on the door and said
your coffee's ready and i was like
okay and it turns out that was code
that was a code that the exec had set up
with her assistant
to make sure that the you know the
meeting was going well her response
then dictated the next action so if they
were trying to get me out of the room or
something like that
then then the assistant would have known
to been like oh well your
your call is on line two and they would
have canned the meeting
so there's there's these subtle things
that you know you may not
you may not inherently know that you
need to look out for but you've got to
be able to control your own nerves
you know come in with a couple stories
come in with a couple of antidotes if
that if that helps you feel better
and just be more personable in a room
so you drove out here from texas to
attend usc
for theater dramatic arts
but now you've focused a lot on writing
where did that shift come in i mean it's
hard to make it as an actor out here
it's really hard um
and i knew that i wanted
to write i just didn't know how to tell
the stories and i think that this is
something that's inherently
different in men and women and like this
this could be just me
but women when they don't know how to do
something
i find that they tend to try to educate
them themselves first before they
they take the leap and do it and that
may be a good thing that may be a bad
thing
i i don't know but that's that's my
particular process i find that a lot of
men are able to just fake it till you
make it and just wing it
um i always get what's called imposter
syndrome
so for me um i had
you know obviously for at that point had
failed with the children's book
you know when i first started writing um
the baltimore school of charm which is
what
launched my screenwriting career i
hadn't been published yet that that came
literally
six weeks after i'd started the ucla
extension
writers program so i was in i was in a
class with with this
professor or i'm sorry a junk professor
uh justin trevor winters
uh he's fantastic really great guy we're
still friends but he was he taught me my
first screenwriting class
so you know as an actor i knew how to i
knew how to break a script down i knew
what the beats were but
you know you never i never looked at it
from the writing standpoint and i
decided this was something that i really
wanted
to try my hand at i really i had a bunch
of stories that i had wanted to tell
and i didn't quite know how to tell them
so i
did what i always do i started to
educate myself on how to do that
so when i got into justin's class at
ucla um and again this is the extension
program
um great program oh it's fantastic i
mean again
this is this is i can fully credit my
education there and the experience of
winning
their screenwriting program to
propelling me to where i am today
um absolutely their instructors are top
notch um
but i was in justin's class and you know
we're
developing the scripts that we want to
start working on and i had two
i had two that i really i had two
stories that i'd really wanted to tell
one of them was the baltimore school of
charm and the other one is a feature
called daruma
which we will be crowdfunding for in
october
we've got it cast we've got you know the
support of a bunch of organizations and
we have alex yellen the director
attached
but i ultimately decided to start
telling the story of the baltimore
school of charm
and what's interesting about this story
is that it it happened i started to tell
it before
the metoo movement really took off it
deals with
you know domestic violence and you know
it has a
very strong female lead um it's set in
the 50s it's inspired by my
grandmother's struggle
um but this is this became a very
personal story when justin was you know
teaching me you know and coaching me
through you know what script to pick he
told me
you know pick the script that you want
to get in bed with for the longest
because you're going to be wrestling
with it for a long time
so and i find that my first screenplay
was the baltimore school charm and that
was the hardest one
because i didn't quite know how all the
pieces fit together
so i worked on that script for about
three years
um before it finally got to its final
state and
the one where it won the competition and
that happened right around when the
metoo movement was happening
so it coincided very nicely with uh
with the current climate how long i'm
sorry did it take you to write the
script
three years three years and so was the
first draft was how long
um i think it was probably 110 pages its
final state is probably i think 97 or 98
pages
now so was it one of these things where
you were able to just
get it all down in a messy form and then
work on it or did it take some time
it took a lot of time um you know this
is this is where you start working
for me my process was figuring out the
beats and the characters
and i you know i know a lot of people
don't put a lot of stock
into the competitions but i do think
that as a new screenwriter or someone
who's finding your way and finding your
process
if you can afford to enter them it's
invaluable because what will happen is
you will get reader feedback on some of
them and you can start tracking your
progress
so for me i did my first draft and i
believe it was a semi-finalist in the
screencraft
fellowship and then from there i was
like okay well this
it's not terrible it's it's okay so i
started to work on it more
and i tweaked it and i would end it in
different competitions
um and it became you know a
second-rounder at austin film festival
um it became a top 15 nichols finalist
so
all of these different iterations and i
would take the feedback and i would
incorporate it into the script
that's not to say that i would change my
vision or my storyline or the characters
but the readers really do take a lot of
time to put in good valuable notes
especially in those top competitions
like aff nichols and screencraft too
but i took the notes and i would
incorporated it and
you know it's very easy to get
discouraged
and disagree with somebody
when they when they try to give you
notes and that i think stunts you
as a writer you have to be open you have
to know when to not compromise your
vision but you also have to know
when to be open to taking feedback so i
allowed myself to do that process
and you know fail for for three years
with this one story i was
kind of you know mucking about with
other ideas too
but eventually um you know i got
notification that this was
baltimore was one of the top three
finalists for the ucla
uh screenwriting competition in the fall
of 2018. no i'm sorry the fall of 2017
i'm sorry fall of 2017 and i was
absolutely stunned and uh
then the announcement went out that it
won and
uh from there um i had been chatting
with a friend of mine
about another project i was working on
and my my phone
literally started to blow up because i'm
not kidding the news
the news that i had won the contest had
been
released by ucla and they send it out to
production companies they send it out to
agencies they send it out to development
execs
and that news uh had gone out while i
was chatting with my friend who happens
to now be my manager i didn't know he
was managing clients at the time because
he was
he was a producer um but i'm starting to
get all of these emails from
you know william morris and caa and
they're like congratulations we'd love
to chat with you and i'm like oh my god
what do i do and he's like what is this
what happened and
uh i told him and he goes we we need to
meet we need to talk so
um we did and i signed with him
and he helped me to organize those
meetings
and you know make sure that i spoke with
the right people and
and that's that got me signed with my
reps today
so you talked about something you called
a general what
what is that so a general is a
meeting that happens between you and a
development executive
it's a very informal meeting and it's
very easy to get worked up
about on your first one if you if you've
never done it before because
you feel like you're you're being judged
and you are to a certain extent
but you should take it as a very
easy informal first date you're meeting
with a production company you're meeting
with a development exec
they've read something you know your
reps or somehow they've gotten some
material that you've written that they
like
uh they're they've read it they want to
meet with you
so this is this is a vetting process for
them to see you know
are you are you good in a room are you
a little odd maybe they don't want to
hire you this is just this is just a way
to make sure that
you know if they go to bat for you that
they're not gonna end up losing
their job so um but you know it's it's a
it's a meeting between you and the
executive
you should always come in with a couple
of ideas um you know they'll have read
either a spec
you know feature film or spec pilots
um and they'll have liked it go in
always take the water because they'll
offer you water
that's a good tip always take the water
because your mouth will get dry
um but yeah it's a very informal meeting
and
you know it's it's easy to say don't put
the pressure on yourself
um if you've never done one
um i
didn't bomb my first one but it
certainly i got better as i
progressed do you think you have to be
empathic or open to be a good writer
i mean isn't that the job of being a
writer is to tell
you know the story of humans
i mean you can you can certainly write a
blockbuster
movie i mean i know that there there are
a lot of big studio
um platforms out there that just you
know tell i'm not going to name any
particular films
but there are some that just don't have
character they're all action and maybe
story lines
but yeah i think in order to to tell
stories that people gravitate to
um you you have to be willing to tell
you know a little bit of yourself in
each one um
one thing that people always ask you
when you are writing
um is why are you the person to tell
this story
why why why should you be the the voice
of this and it's easier
to i don't want to say prove but it's
easier
to to persuade people that you are the
the right person
to tell a particular story if you
yourself can relate to it
um i think that's what we're all looking
for you know anytime that we go to a
movie
we're looking to experience a kind of
catharsis you know we're looking to
experience some kind of human emotion
um i find that my best pieces my best
work
are the ones that i've really put myself
into and they have
a bit of me in um like like the
baltimore school of charm there's a
reason that story is so
impactful and there's a reason that it
resonates with people is because it's
it's inspired by my family it's it's
something
that you know i've lived through it's
something that other women have lived
through
it's it's a bit of me on that page
um absolutely you need to be
empathetic sure and at the same time
being empathetic and open
also has its drawbacks in that maybe
things wound you more
or it's it's more intense for you so how
are you able to
be open and sensitive to things that are
coming at you for story ideas
but then also be able to receive notes
and sometimes they're not always going
to be positive or
go into a room and maybe you read that
room and it's not friendly because
i think that that's learning the writing
process you can learn
you know it's like let's imagine we're
building a building
you've got to have some kind of a floor
plan to do it right you've got to know
the rules before you can break them
so if you can learn structural
engineering and how to put it together
then you can shape it into whatever
shape you want it to be you know you can
you can make a skyscraper with you know
turrets on it if you wanted to
but that's how you that's how you find
your voice that's how you start making
stories your own um learn the rules
before you break them
so you know you can't tell such an
emotionally overdrawn story
you know for where you've got your lead
crying or being assaulted or abused for
you know two and a half hours
nobody's gonna want to see that i think
that you as a writer need to understand
that you have an
a duty to your audience to make sure you
tell a story that moves forward and you
tell the story that progresses
don't skimp on character certainly save
those those moments you know of great
emotion
but learn how to construct your story
first you're serving a lot of masters
when you're when you're writing
and if you don't have good structure
i mean unfortunately that's your story
will fall apart
how does someone become good as a writer
you said it first you weren't sure you
could do it but you wanted to
definitely learn have that as a
safeguard you didn't want to just try it
and say you were a writer without doing
it
you know i still have problems saying
i'm a writer i don't know when when do
you ever become
good i mean if you're if you're maya
angelou or somebody like that then
you're definitely a good writer
but i think i don't know i think
i think asking yourself the question
always wanting to be better always
knowing that you can dig deeper and
always finding that you can do something
better
that will help you lead to improving
your process
and i i i want to stay away from using
labels like
good or great because that kind of puts
you know that puts a lot of pressure on
yourself
especially for somebody that's just
starting out you have to be okay with
failing
you only need one story
to spark the next thing in your career i
failed for three years with baltimore
um and then when i finally got it right
it struck the right chord
what do you think the difference was
just working on it dishoning it
i think i think it was my
dogged perseverance of not giving up on
it i
i wanted people to see what i saw
and i had to find a way to communicate
that out
and i think just writing draft after
draft after draft after draft and i've
probably gone through 30 iterations of
that script
you know with time with time i've
certainly gotten better
i've improved my own process so i can
shorten that writing cycle
but the first one i had no idea what i
was doing
what were some of the notes that you got
and how much of the
feedback did you incorporate to change i
mean
i incorporated feedback from a variety
of sources i incorporated it from some
of the competitions that i was in some
of the
instructors at ucla um
character was one of the things that
people
would really hone in on i mean obviously
there are things like well this is a bit
of a plot hole you may want to look at
this but those are the obvious things
um but people would always talk about
making
the character more in depth like what
what little things can you do
to to make a character stick out in
someone's mind
um there's a a second female
lead in baltimore it's a young girl
named shasta
she's 17 and so i wanted there's there's
a relationship between millie the lead
and shasta so millie is
trying to outrun the law and she gets
stuck in a small town
where you know she can't get out of it
and she ends up helping
shasta the young girl there but shasta
has has a stutter so
that was one thing that i was able to to
develop with shasta initially she didn't
have a stutter
um but she i gave her that impediment
to help show her relationship with the
world around her
so i think that there are certain traits
there are certain manners since there's
certain things
that you can do to you know just build
up your character and
obviously give them a backstory but that
will inform the decisions on how they
interact with the world
did you miss the two characters when you
were finished writing was it hard for
you to give them up
um i tell you what's going to be hard
for me
is when it gets made you know as a
writer you typically don't have
any control over something when it
leaves your hands
so i hope that the company that
ends up buying baltimore school of charm
i hope that they do those characters
justice because it's not a lo
it's not a movie of the week you know
it's it's certainly not a melodrama
it's it's a very strong powerful piece
and it's my hope that a female director
will will end up helming it um i think
that that's important
to actually authentically tell the story
um
you know they're like your characters
are like your children when you send
them out in the world you hope that they
they're received well and that they do
well
what were so the fee the feedback
initially was that the
the character at least the main one
wasn't as fleshed out and so you really
worked on
making her just more three-dimensional
more three-dimensional yeah
and so when you finally uh
sorry you won it was the ucla
screenwriting competition okay
their extension their extension okay and
so they
these different agencies just found your
emails obviously
no what happened is when when there are
different categories within the
uh the competition so it's best feature
it's best spec pilot and then best pilot
so and then you're ranked one two and
three so there's
a total of nine awards that give out
that that they've given out and then
there's you know obviously first place
second place third place
so when they send the announcement out
and they've got a list of you know
thousands of executives and agents that
you know they've
spent years cultivating relationships
with
um when the announcement goes out they
put out
an ad in variety announcing it and then
they also
do a mass email to all of these
executives
so that's how they got tipped off and
um you know you you put first place
feature
on a competition like that and it's
going to spark some interest
and fortunately it did unfortunately it
got me you know the reps that i have
today
so then part of having a rep is they're
submitting you to work on shows how like
how does this work
um so typically what happens there's a
there's an issue right now with the wga
and the ata so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna go into that in this
particular interview because i'm there
are many people that are
much more uh positioned or much better
positioned to speak on that than i am
but typically what happens is you know
if you've got a spec pilot or a spec
feature
they will take that material and they
will send it out to different exhaust
development execs and studios and you
know
see if it's a match um and they could
you know
you can write on assignments so let's
just say if you meet with the
development exec and they like your
writing
i'm like while i've got this project
would you be interested in taking a
crack at it
so so that's the job of an agent is to
find their clients work
and so how much advanced notice do you
get when you have a meeting
i have one this week that has been on my
calendar for six weeks
oh that's good so you have your outfit
everything's ready yeah yeah
although it i i had a i had one a couple
weeks ago i had a general a couple weeks
ago and she said
she actually had um an intern and she
asked if it was okay if the interns sat
in on the meeting
and i think that's totally fine i mean
it wasn't gonna throw me off my game
but we talked about it later she was
like she was like i think you
set the bar a little too high for for
generals because she said
we've had some interesting people come
in here she said yeah one of the one of
the worst
uh pieces of advice that i've ever heard
writers being given is to dress like
your genre
and i was like what does that mean she
was like i don't know
but i was like i don't i was like what
am i what is what are you supposed to do
i guess if you write action adventure
you're supposed to dress
i don't know but don't do that that's
bad advice
um so just wear something like you know
business casual or
i mean don't dress like a schlub you
know make sure that you look
professional
and neat clothes that you're comfortable
in
i mean you're you're not you're you're
not
trying to over impress you know you're
just just be yourself
just look neat and professional just be
yourself then how long did it take for
you to develop sort of like the pitch
that is you because they want to ask you
this and sometimes people are
comfortable and sometimes
so tell me about yourself how long did
that take it changes every time i go
into a room
you have to learn how to reach your
audience because you may be dealing with
somebody who
um is more closed off and maybe they
don't want to know so much personal
information about yourself
i think instead of developing your pitch
you need to know how to you really need
to know your story
because you need you can't tell your
pitch the same way every single time
because then it sounds
canned it sounds like you're reading it
off of an index card
and nobody wants to be you know read a
powerpoint slide
you need to be in a position to
authentically tell your story
at any given you know notice
how does someone know which story they
should write you should write the one
you're afraid to tell
if it scares you then you you know you
need to do it
i have a couple like that right now that
i'm working on um
i have a play that is going to be going
up off-broadway
next year um it was it was actually one
of the very first pieces of writing i
had ever done i was in a group
called the los angeles writers center
for years when i was kind of
dipping my toe into to writing and
decided i wasn't very good at it
but i had written a play um it's a
two-act play um
and i wrote it in 2007 and it's actually
scary how
how applicable it is to today's current
climate
it's about a mexican-american soldier
who's injured in iraq and his illegal
brother is killed while they're serving
over there so this is right after 9 11
and he comes back to los angeles and he
discovers that his two younger siblings
have been put into
foster care and his parents have
deported been deported and i wrote this
in 2007
oh wow yeah and it was it was it's
called borderline
um and it was actually a semi-finalist
at aff
last year again as soon as as soon as i
started to build up my own confidence in
my writing i took off some stuff and i
dusted them off and i started to submit
them out
and i have a friend of mine who i went
to usc with
who runs a theater um up in manhattan
and
this is a issue that is that she's very
passionate about
and i'd never connected the dots before
but i sent it to her and she said
do you want to i said do you want to
read this and she said yeah absolutely
so
she read it and she goes why don't we do
a reading so we did a reading in april
this year in new york
and we have decided to workshop it um
with the intent of
putting it up in the fall of 2020. now i
have not done any of the rewrites yet
because i am
silently criticizing myself because how
do i take the enormity of everything
that's going on
right now and put it into a two-act play
and again you know why am i the person
to tell the story
and this is something that i wrestled
with and i
i hope it comes out well i hope i tell
an authentic story
and and i hope i create something that
really resonates and moves people
but my job as a writer is to really take
myself in this particular instance is to
take myself out of it
and to put my fears beside you know
behind me so i can
so i can drastic peace we need writers
right now more than ever
because a lot of people's voices are
being quieted
and this is not the time does it scare
you of course it scares me
of course it's a children's story yeah
absolutely why does it scare you tell
that story
um you know i certainly don't want
anything to ring
inauthentic or hollow um
and of course you know if i'm if i'm
telling a story that doesn't necessarily
relate
to you know my own upbringing you know
my family
is not immigrants i mean they're they're
from italy but that was you know
two generations ago so i wasn't directly
impacted by that growing up
but there are a lot of people that are
hurting right now there are a lot of
people that are struggling
um so for me to have to you know
that's a lot of weight to carry on my
shoulders but i
put that weight upon myself because i
feel like this is a very important story
to tell
and it's one that i want to tell um so
i'm doing
a lot of research right now i'm speaking
with immigration attorneys
i am reading you know news articles i'm
doing a ton of research
um it's it's my job to tell the story
the best that i can i'm crafting the
story
as well um but i find
you know this this other piece that i've
worked on daruma
um this this particular story it it
stars two disabled leads but the movie
is not about their disability
and i i wrote this as a way to deal with
my own grief after a member of my family
became
paralyzed in an accident now the story
is
not about them it's it's not about them
but it's inspired by them
and i went through
dozens of drafts of that script because
i wanted to tell an authentic story now
i'm i'm not a disabled
person i the last thing i wanted to do
was to put anything on the page that was
you know inauthentic offensive i i put
that script through so many sensitivity
reads
which is which is an important thing to
do as a writer
and that's not to say shy away from
telling you know racy material
or things you know that are taboo
definitely tell those stories
but it's important in this level of
heightened awareness
to to put your things through a
sensitivity read and i changed things
about that script
i i i took things out you know one thing
that i
i kick myself for um are
one of our leads john um in the script
his
his character's called is robert but
robert is a double arm amputee
and i wrote robert how i thought
a double arm amputee would be very
limited action very limited movement and
then we cast john lawson
and my god that guy he is a private
pilot
he can scuba dive he's an amazing
photographer
as a writer when i initially did i i
limited him
and it took me meeting john and
interacting and really ingratiating
myself with that community
to open myself up and that's how you
tell an authentic story
what is the sensitivity read so a
sensitivity read
is to put your material in front of you
know
a person that you are writing about so
let's just say that you're writing about
a disabled person or maybe you're
writing about somebody who
has hiv or maybe you're writing about an
immigrant
maybe you're writing about somebody with
topical issues you know and anything
that can be considered
emotionally or politically charged so
dealing with
issues of race color economic class
anything that can be uh
possibly disparaging to a particular
group of people it's important that you
share those materials you you put it in
front of you know
readers and you do a table read you know
do it do uh
have actors read the parts back to you
and
you know there was in my play borderline
um
one of the feedback uh one of the pieces
of feedback that i'm working into
i have sort of a greek chorus of dia de
los muertos characters
and of course that's you know that's
something that's very
uh traditionally you know mexican um
they're uh in in my story they function
as a greek chorus
and they're kind of ominous figures but
i had a latino cast
and you know two out of three of them
were like
you really need to be a little bit more
positive with these guys because you
know the dia de los muertos is a way to
honor
family and tradition and these guys kind
of come across
as as baddies and i'm like okay i didn't
know that
so as a writer you need to be open to
hearing those kinds of suggestions
because you know every everybody knows
the stories you know
cowboys and indians you know what it
would a classically
machismo you know imperialistic way of
thinking
and nobody would make that movie these
days
like it's it's it wouldn't happen
you know you go back and you look at a
lot of movies from your childhood or the
90s or in a lot of these raunchy
comedies
they're creepy you know if you you look
at a lot of
um movies now like especially in the 80s
like that's rape culture and that
perpetuates things you know people
consume the media that you write
it's it's important to have people look
at your materials to make sure
it kind of passes a smell test now
that's that's the
that's a sensitivity rate interesting
and
what about the criticism that somebody
who hasn't been through something
shouldn't be allowed to tell it i feel
like in this climate because somebody's
voice may be censored or they may be
afraid to tell that story
that somebody else who may feel like i
don't know society might view them as
they have more freedoms to tell a story
should be able to then get that story
out there i have two
two things to say about that um the
director of my play the stage reading
that we did she's she's
latinx uh amazing young auteur
we had a conversation you know we were
getting ready for pre-production
and she asked me she said are you or you
hispanic descent i said no i'm not she
was or your spanish is pretty good and i
was like well i worked for the
translator
to to get that going and um she asked me
she was why are you the one to tell the
story she's like you know you're a white
woman
why are you the one to to tell this
story
and my answer was that no one else is
telling it
no one else is telling the story and you
know regardless of my
background or my skin color or anything
i live in this world and these are
issues that i care about
so if i care about them enough to try to
talk about them and to try to push them
out into the world
you know my my story may not be the end
all be
all you know you know end of subject
matter it's that's not going to be the
case
but this is something that i care deeply
about and
i you know i live in this world i'm
impacted by these issues too
so that's that's one way that i address
those
particular questions i had a general
a couple weeks ago with another
production company a very well-known
film company and you know as a writer
you're always constantly going through
i'm at least i am personally you know
self-doubt and kind of self-loathing and
thinking that you suck
um but she was talking about a lot of
the pieces that i write
and she noticed a common thread the
development exactly i was
sitting with she was like you tend to
really give characters that don't have
a voice a voice i i started to look back
at the pieces that i would write
or that that i've been working on and
you know when you look at borderline
that deals with the immigration issues
and
daruma which deals with disability and i
have another one where the lead is a
little deaf girl
um and then you deal with domestic
violence issues in baltimore
and i didn't really
realize that and i mean even though you
know i didn't necessarily have
the best upbringing and i've certainly
struggled i
and she said it very eloquently she goes
you're using your privilege to give
voice to those
who don't have voice so that's something
i actually walked out of the office a
little teary
but that really rang true to me
what makes a great story
wow there's a that's a that's a loaded
question
i mean character i think that you can i
think that you can
forgive a lot of things if you have a
character that's interesting to watch
on the screen of the stage what ruins
the story for you
like what takes you out of it if i'm
reading a story
if i'm just looking at something on the
page um
lazy writing like if somebody has
so many typos and plot holes
um i once had to i didn't have to i
offered to read a script from somebody
um just to give my notes and my feedback
and
within 10 pages i was just angry because
it was it was
it had so many typos it had so many
errors there was just
grammatical mistakes there was no
consideration for time and location and
there was just
i was why was i reading that like it was
it was a clear indication to me that the
writer did not respect my time
because they did not do their due
diligence they did not
what they handed me was not their best
effort
so that took me completely out of the
story i can forgive a couple of typos
every now and again i mean i make them
myself i submitted something that i
found a typo one like 10 minutes later
and i was kicking myself
but i knew that i'd comb through that
document enough times to make sure that
there wasn't
you know a lot of glaring mistakes but
for somebody to be
just so blatantly blase
with you know punctuation and grammar
and
basic elements like like time and space
i i won't work i won't work with them
can you give me an example
of what a plot hole is yeah so this
particular story that i would that i was
referencing
they um were discussing
a geographical location you know set in
the southwest
and then all of a suddenly you know in
in the time frame of the story
three hours later they somehow ended up
2 000 miles away
at in a totally different location and
there was no consideration as to how the
characters got there
it was just what like how did you
suddenly end up there
it was a massive plot hole okay yeah
that makes sense yeah
it's like okay took me completely out of
the story
so in other words um how somebody's
getting from point a to point b
there's no consideration in the story
for that i mean you don't have to spoon
feed your audience
everything but if you've you know
the audience will sit within the rules
that you established
so it's very important to establish the
rules of your universe this is this goes
for people that write sci-fi this goes
for people that write
um you know magical you know uh
stories like you know the world of harry
potter something like that the rules of
the magic are very clearly defined
once you start to break the you're the
rules that you
set up or you start to give too many
exceptions your whole world falls apart
so aside from being scared to write
something how do you know your
protagonist is someone that you want to
write about
you want to spend like years working
with this has happened to me on a couple
of occasions
but eventually my character starts
speaking to me they have gotten so
vocal that they actually start talking
with their own voices
and to me that's almost like a state of
reaching like a runner's high
it's it's rarely achieved when when i've
done it
i've done it in about four of my scripts
but those to me are the characters that
have
uh the strongest voices and certainly
have been the pieces and the projects
that have been put out into the world
and have gotten me
um you know where i am and the attention
that i've gotten
that's that's key to me is when those
voices are so clear
it's like when i'm writing dialogue i
don't even have to think about what the
response would be the character just
automatically says it to me it's it's a
weird phenomenon but it
it does happen have you ever had it
where the
characters aren't speaking to you and
then you're like
i don't think this is going to work yeah
absolutely
i mean part of being a good writer is
knowing when to
walk away from something i had a book
that i wrote that was
42 000 words long the first book that
i'd ever written and i was shopping it
around
and i found myself going to edit it and
trying to figure out what to do with it
and like why it wasn't working why it
wasn't resonating with people
and then i realized myself you know i'm
10 pages into it and i'm bored
the character just had no voice um
so i realized that that was a problem
and
it's it's important to recognize those
things in your writing you have to
you have to you know certainly be aware
of what's working but you also have to
be
self-aware enough to accept what's not
working
do you think you were scared to give the
appropriate voice to that character
or it's just from the get-go it just
wasn't the right sort of combination
i think it just wasn't i was trying to
force something i was trying to i was
trying to force a narrative
and you know i'm not saying you so you
shouldn't wait for inspiration to strike
because you may never get inspired it's
important to keep pushing through and
keep pushing
and you know write every day even if
it's even if it's bad you can always go
back and edit i mean one of the
wonderful things and i forget who says
this but you you can't edit a blank page
edit so i mean obviously edit but you've
got to write but it's it's important to
to understand that there are sometimes
it's not working that's not to say trash
the idea
there may be a time you know five or ten
years later
you'll come back and you're like oh my
god this is this is the key that makes
that work this is the piece that makes
it fit together
so just because you don't have it at the
offset doesn't mean that it's a failure
it's never going to work
certainly save that work um but just
recognize when it's time to maybe move
on from something
can you take us back to the first
character
that innocent started talking to you
that i mean it was like this real person
that was like almost in your ear
what was that like so the first
character that started to talk to me
was for actually the first tv pilot that
i wrote when i got signed by my agents i
didn't have a tv sample
and they were like well we need a tv
sample to send you out so
i wrote a pilot um and the lead
in that show i'd been mulling this idea
for so long um i actually wrote it
in about a week um and the lead
character in that like she
she just been so real um
that when i started to write her out i
mean she's got a best friend
and a daughter in this very complicated
relationship with her job and her
ex-husband
and she was just so real to me
and the character name is maggie um
whenever she would talk it was just her
voice just just coming out
and that in turn just formulated you
know her
her viewpoint of the world just
formulated my
uh decisions with the the characters
around her and
everyone in the story just just came to
life and
it's become my signature piece that my
reps send out to get
my generals in my meetings took you a
week to write it yeah
and how many pages is it uh this is 59
pages long
because it's a tv it's like an hour tv
i know you're incredibly busy you're
doing many different things where do you
find the time to write and do you write
every day
i try to write every day um actually i
take the train a lot in los angeles
and i will write my ideas you know i
will i will work in a note
you know my my iphone i will type on my
uh notes there
um i do write every day um for me
i find that mornings are better
with coffee you know when i'm when i'm
by myself and things are quiet in the
house
um that's to me the the time that i like
to do it
and again mean you can't you can't wait
for inspiration to strike because you
may never end up writing something you
have to keep pushing every single day
i tend to like to keep a lot of projects
in the air
at the same time um whether that's
developing a new pilot or developing a
new feature
i was chasing the rights to a book i've
got i've got this
play that's going up now um
the the difference between wanting to
write and and being a writer
is writing you're a writer when you say
you are
first off what does the word daruma mean
and when did you start writing it
so i actually started to write daruma
um after a member of my own family
suffered a
spinal cord injury um they had a
motorcycle accident
and became a t45 and six paraplegic and
i wrote
this short as a way to process my own
grief i mean i
you know as a writer that's how i
dealt with my feelings it's i mean it's
devastating
i mean disability can affect anybody at
any given point in time i mean it is it
is
a universal thing that everybody deals
with
um but i when i was at usc
i studied asian art history for one of
my general
requirement classes and one of my
classes
we studied this painting called ika
showing his severed arm to daruma
i didn't know anything about this
painting but it was written in the
muramachi period by a guy named
sashutoyo
it shows the daruma which is the bodhi
dharma
the guy that founded zen buddhism now
the legend goes is that he meditated in
a cave
for nine years and his limbs fell away
he had no need for them anymore
so he was this sort of round object you
know what i mean he had no no arms no
legs nothing
um and the painting depicts this guy
named ika
who was a would-be pupil a disciple who
was so desperate to study with the
daruma
so ika severs his own arm and he
presents it to the daruma
and he wakes the daruma from a trance
and the daruma's like
you've missed the point of the lessons
and he turns them away
and i was so haunted by this painting
because it was so
garish and it was it was just so ugly um
but what happened was when my family
member was recovering
from their injury they you know spent
months in rehabilitation
they were roomed with a young man who
had lost both of his arms in an
electrical accident
and you know they had both turned 21
and they both had their lives ahead of
them they were both you know just just
starting
and you could see you know the
indomitable spirit that they had you
know they were you know getting
all kinds of mischief and stuff into the
into the recovery center and
they were still the same people they had
just had these life-changing
injuries but they were the same people
um so this is where the idea of daruma
came because here was one young man who
just lost his arms
and here's another young man who had
just lost both of his legs
so together i you know the the theme of
this is you know
it becomes one person now if you
look online you will see what a daruma
doll is now daruma doll is a
round doll that is popular in japanese
culture
when you get one you color in one eye
black and you make a wish
when your wish comes true you color in
the other eye
so you know the daruma features as an
underlying
theme in the story but the story i wrote
i wrote a fictionalized version of this
relationship that unfolded
so this is a story that follows a very
bitter angry paraplegic named
patrick who discovers that he's got a
four-year-old daughter from a one-night
stand
before he got injured and he takes her
for an insurance payout
but he quickly learns that he he can't
parent
so he has to take her to live across the
country with her maternal grandparents
and the only person that can help him
make this journey is his double arm
amputee
so that's that's the the story of daruma
and that's something that
i've been working on for a number of
years now and
we have been connecting with
organizations
like the reeve foundation the rutterman
family foundation
respectability we've been working with
those organizations to help build a
platform
to get this story out um you know
one of the things that i think was
shocking to me
when i you know won the contest and i
got signed and i got wrecked i thought
you know this is that i
my my screenwriting career is gonna
gonna take off and that's not
necessarily the case
you still have to be your own advocate
and you still have to be prepared
to pursue your passion projects because
not everybody's going to see the vision
that you have for something
now we're fortunate in that we have you
know the team with jerome has
um you know we've partnered with people
who have seen the vision
we're authentically casting these roles
we're we are casting
two disabled actors to play these these
lead roles
um i don't want to have a situation
where we've got an able-bodied actor
who can you know play a disabled rule
that's
not what we're setting out to do so
it's it's an uphill battle to produce
this project but we're doing a crowd
funding
um october 1st with seed and spark which
is an indie filmmaker platform and i
encourage anybody who
has a script or they want to shoot a
proof of concept and they don't know
where to go
look there look at other projects look
at what other people are doing
it's a great place to connect with other
filmmakers too yeah they have some
fantastic campaigns
and you have a website that's already
set up for daruma i do
i do actually and i think one of the
most interesting things about
that website is that we have put content
from
other sources like respectability and
the ford foundation
they all have toolkits for disability
inclusion in hollywood
so as a writer we talked about
sensitivity reads earlier
these their pdfs that you can download
from the website they actually have
different tips and steps that you as a
writer or a producer or a filmmaker
can draw from and put into your own work
and i think it's great too that you
already have your website ready to go i
mean i saw some of the cast
yeah and your director and his bio and
your bio yep so i think that's great so
many people i know they don't
it's not ready yet and you know i think
it's great because you but
right now it's uh august and so we have
a few months and that
i mean it's fully fleshed out website
looks great well we actually put that
website up in
almost a year and a half ago oh you did
oh yeah that website's been up for a
while
one of the things that we've learned
about this process is that nobody's
gonna do it for you
you have to be able to and i mean this
is where i put my producer hat on
you have to be able to just draw that
line in the sand and be like okay this
is it we're going
and i find that when you start to get
people to
to come on board one of the and one day
i'm going to write a book about this one
one day this is going to be my
my book to film making but do you know
the story about phil or a stone soup
silverstein no no it's actually it's a
it's a it's a old
folk uh folks tale uh there's a man who
wanders into a village
and he's hungry and nobody will help him
and all of the just all the villagers
turn away
so i think all right well i have a rock
so he goes to the center of town and
he's like
i have a magic rock this magic rock will
make amazing soup for everybody to eat
he's like well in order to get started i
just need a little bit of water so
someone's like all right i'll buy into
this i'll give you a little bit of water
he's like okay well great so now that we
have this water and this magic rock we
just need a little bit of fire
so the doors oh i've got some wood so
i'll contribute some wood and gradually
everybody starts contributing to this
pot and they make this amazing soup
so if you look at the process of making
an independent feature like we're doing
with daruma
as sort of making a film soup you you
start to look at
you know you bring this to the table and
go well i can bring this to the table
and you start building a team and a
collaboration and eventually you get to
the point where we are
where you you know we did the website
then we did a casting and we connected
with um
you know casting directors and agents
and we started to
actually cast you know disabled actors
in the lead roles and that opened up the
doors to this other community and now
we're
partnering with organizations and it's
one thing on top of each another and
it's
it's very easy to get discouraged in
this process because it takes a long
time
but honestly these things should take a
long time they
they should because they they need to be
good they they're important
so that's really interesting so that you
don't want to rush it because it means a
lot to you instead of just putting it
out
and it's half done and then there's
criticisms and you go yeah i know
that's that's smart i mean it's it's one
thing to wait for something to happen
and then it's another to be like you
know what
it's it's time it's
it's finding a balance so we we could
wait forever
and you know look for the right you know
financers
to to come and give us money to make
this project but the fact that matters
is that
casting to lead actors to you know that
have disabilities
that's not really something people want
to take a gamble on that's not something
you know a lot of people you know as a
producer or you know a film financier or
whatever
would be like well what's who's who's
your lead actor because their job is to
make money you know they've got
they've got to pay their bills they've
got a you know kids to send to school or
whatever
it's not a risk that people are
necessarily willing to take
but that doesn't mean that the project
shouldn't be made
so it's up to you to find creative ways
to make it happen and you're also the
writer
writer and so you said it's loosely
based on a family member it's not their
exact story no it's not it's not loosely
based on them at all actually
no no my this family member never
discovered that they had a child from a
one-night stand it's it's it was written
as a way for me to process
uh my own grief what was very important
for me
about this particular story if you look
at
most narratives where you have a
disabled character
the storyline tends to go from being
able-bodied
to having a tragic accident and then
suddenly
being disabled and then living your life
you know then that's that's the
inspirational part of the story
it was very important for me to tell a
story
where it had two leads that were
disabled and that that wasn't a plot
point that wasn't a device
it's nothing for them to overcome it it
just is what it is because
listen 25 of the american population
lives with a disability
yet two percent are represented on
screen
so we talked about you know using your
privilege as a platform for
underrepresented voices
this is single-handedly for me the most
important project that i'm working on
right now
what was the writing process like for
daruma lonely
it was really lonely um i
kept this story in a drawer for years um
again it was it was a way for me to
process something that had happened that
was you know very very personal
um and affected me greatly but you know
i i can't i can't necessarily say this
this may be awful but like
had i never personally experienced what
a disability or an injury you know was
like
with with with a family member this
might not have been a story that i had
ever
you know told i and me and i'm not
i'm not a disabled myself but
i am the person to tell this story
because i want to tell it i want to tell
it authentically
but the process for writing this was was
very lonely because i didn't have anyone
to share it with
and it sat in a drawer for about you
know 10 years and it was
awful it was awful but that was wrong
well i'd started writing it as a short
first
um and then again i'm as i'm as i'm
developing my craft and honing my
process
and i took it you know i took an outline
to my class with justin trevor winters
and you know he looked at that one and
he looked at the baltimore school of
charm and he was like
you need to write the baltimore's
bulldog so i did that and then as i
started to develop that i wanted to
branch out and work on other projects
so i started to work on revisions of
daruma that were all equally terrible
but i started to enter the script into
different screen
screen reading competitions and i got
feedback and i got
notes and over the past the course of
about two two and a half years
it became its current iteration um and
then we
you know it found its director alex
yellen he
i gave it to him to read um and by
page three he's laughing and i'm like
what is so funny why are you laughing
he's like he's like this is hilarious
i'm like it's not supposed to be a
comedy
and he's like but what you've written is
really funny so
he read it and he could see what i saw
and he was like
i would really like to direct this and i
was like okay
so we now have alex attached to it as a
director
and then we cast john and toby um to
shoot our proof of concept
uh last fall just so we could you know
it's so much easier to visually tell
your story so i
i encourage you if you can shoot a proof
of concept to do that especially if
you're trying to produce your own
feature
um but from there you know i had my
actors read the script
and i talked about you know doing
sensitivity reads and
john lawson the guy that plays robert
like i said i had initially written the
character that was very limited
and john can do so much i mean you would
you would assume that somebody with you
know no
arms would you know not be able to do
the things john does but that was my own
naivete so with daruma i know you're
launching a crowdfunding on sedan spark
in october
of this year but did you also try to get
a production company
because we've talked with a couple
people we've had interest i mean we've
had a lot of people come to us to say
this is an amazing idea
like i love this who are you casting as
the leads and then when we say that
we're actually authentically casting the
disabled
you know our two disabled leads
enthusiasm fizzles because again
you've got to look at what translates to
to box office sales so
it's so much easier to attach a name
actor to a to a script
and i mean especially something that's
got you know these challenging
characters to play
um but i don't want to compromise the
vision
of this project like the intent of it is
to not
the intent is to to be a vehicle and a
platform for
for underrepresented voices and i i want
it to be the first of its kind i mean
can you
name another movie like this well i
can think of where there's been named
actors that have played
disabled individuals right not um
no it's very rare to see except for
dodgeball sorry
i mean they did have well i mean people
with i don't know if they were
uh autistic or what different you know
but dodgeball had
right people though but the butt of a
joke right
yes yeah so disparaging very true but
you know it's it's very rare to come
across something
completely new and this is a story
that has never been told before and
especially in the way that we that we're
wanting to tell it
so that in of itself is very unique and
that's not something that i'm willing to
compromise on which is why we're going
the hard route and we're doing this
ourselves
what roadblocks have you run into with
daruma in terms of
you've presented it to production
companies other things maybe that we're
not aware of
i mean i think that's the problem most
indie filmmakers running into is
financing
so where do you get the money from like
how do you how do you put this into
reality
we've done three different budgets we've
done one in a million we've done it half
a million and then we've done this
bootstrap one that we're going to be
crowdfunding for
in october um you know there's
there's challenges with every project so
first of all like is your idea good can
you get it on the page can you
articulate it
can you start finding people that
believe in your vision
this has been something that we've been
working on solidly now
for the last three years and we're right
now
at the point where we've we feel like
we've gotten
our platform and our village of people
and supporters together and we're ready
to
to take the next step and attempt to
raise the funds for production
um but again you know this is this is
something that every
project runs into is who comes up with
the money
so what are you learning from these
obstacles
well one i'm learning that nobody is
going to do it for you
you have to be able to do it yourself
you have to put yourself in
uncomfortable positions
and be prepared um you know again if
you're not good at pitching
then you need to to become good at
pitching you need to
to learn how to tell your story you need
to learn how to tell your story
succinctly
um you know i'm also learning to
celebrate the small victories
just because you know you don't get from
a
to z immediately you can't
neglect every step that goes in between
you know like for us
getting uh our cast attached our amazing
cast attached that was a win that was a
celebration
then getting our our film uh our
uh proof of concept shot you know we
while we were doing that the woolsey
fire was going on
we lost a location actually we lost a
couple locations during that because
we were going to be shooting up in agora
hills um
and we ended up we we called in a couple
favors and begged borrowed and stealed
our stole it was terrible english it was
terrible
and we big bored and stole um but we
ended up getting
you know some new friends along the way
who helped us but it's very important
and
actually a friend of mine a friend of
mine told us to be a producer a friend
of mine when when i won the contest
it's very important to celebrate the
small victories
when i was at usc i had a professor
amazing
on camera professor named joe hacker
and he would coach young actors you know
how to
go about their career and he loved to
tell
the story about when he was younger and
he was working on broadway and he went
up to his
idol and was like you know i want to be
where you are how do i get to be where
you are
and the response was you can't
but there are a million ways and he
always liked to tell us that you know
every small thing every small success
was one pearl on a very long strand
so you just have to keep threading that
needle and finding the courage
and the strength to keep going great
story what does it take to get a
hollywood movie made
i don't know i haven't made one yet
um i imagine it takes quite a bit of
luck so
um do you want to make hollywood movies
i feel like they're
i have some scripts that i've written
that are that are certainly more
commercial
than the ones that i have um you know
i'm working towards
but i think that as a young screenwriter
you know
starting out it's very important to
establish your voice
and your brand um
it you know i have a lot of
fun projects that i don't spend my time
working on or developing
because i'm not there yet you know those
could be the quote-unquote hollywood
movies
i feel like at this point you know i'm
proving myself and i'm i'm
you know putting my work out there and
i've got to put my best foot forward and
you know maybe a hollywood movie isn't
the thing that i want to build my
platform on
um i'm not looking to make a quick block
you know i mean don't get me wrong you
know
being paid for writing is awesome when i
got my first check as a writer i was
i took a picture of it because it was an
incredible feeling
um but you have to consider that you
know you're in it for the long haul
it's very easy i think for a lot of
people to burn out
and if you can find your voice and your
passion and the things that keep you
drive you know keep your drive going
that will sustain a career does it scare
you to write non-hollywood movies
no because i find that that's the thing
that i i tend to play in the most i mean
where i'm emotionally at my head spaces
at
the thing that scares me is writing you
know science fiction
and things like that because i feel like
maybe i don't have the imagination to
come up
with the world you know of this maybe a
post-apocalyptic or something maybe i
would be very afraid of
doing something cliche how do you top
star trek how do you how do you top star
wars
you know and who who am i to even try um
but
again you know we go back to the point
great storytelling isn't about these set
pieces it's about the characters
so if you look at most science fiction
pieces they're actually
stories about political turmoil or
refugees or something like that so
again go back to character go back to
your story
have you ever thought about stopping and
said yourself you know
there's easier ways to spend my life all
the time
i mean i've you know carved out a career
for myself as a marketing
and creative professional you know
copywriting and art directing and things
like that and
if i really gave myself to that maybe i
could be very successful but i feel like
there would
i there would be this hole inside of me
that would just be
devoid um you know i think that maybe
maybe i'm not very smart maybe i should
have given up a long time ago because i
keep
you know putting myself through this and
you know trying and keep going
but i think that that's part of the
challenge that a lot of writers face is
the self-doubt
and the imposter syndrome and especially
as a woman and trying to break through
in this industry it's very hard um yeah
you grapple with that all the time and
writing by nature is a very solitary
activity
um it's it's very easy to
want to throw in the towel and that's
why it's so important to celebrate those
little victories just
one little thing you know one one
connection one
one interview one you know chance
encounter
could change your world but by naming
the imposter syndrome and sort of
calling it out does that
take away its power a little bit you
have to be aware of it when it's
happening i mean there are times
you know and i think that this comes
with age and maturity as well i mean
certainly i'm i'm more grounded now that
i am in my 30s than i was in my 20s
um i'm able to own my mistakes more
readily i'm able to
objectively look at myself and
you know separate
the the need of me that need or the part
of me that needs approval
um to the part of me that that you know
is trying to
to create something as well so that if i
can give myself enough space
to fail then i can i can help overcome
that imposter syndrome but it's
it's not an easy thing to do and i know
a lot of people grapple with it
but when you're in that space of writing
about just some character that is our
it's so real it's speaking to you
it's kind of scary it might be a little
edgy is that
sounds like it's not being an imposter
by any means that's such a rare
state of enlightenment that you know
it's like i said it's like
it's almost like getting a runner's high
it's not it doesn't happen all the time
but it is
magic when it does what's the hardest
part of writing a screenplay for you
getting to the end of it it's so easy
sometimes to just
give up and say that it's you know you
can't finish it so
i always try to start with an outline i
always outline my work first and i know
a lot of people
don't work this way but i find that if
my outline falls apart then my
screenplay falls apart
so when i was first starting off of
course i didn't necessarily
put the time into developing the
outlines or the character beats or doing
all of this
you know back writing but that's
actually where the writing starts to
happen
is when you can you know the the pilot
that i wrote in a week
the reason i was able to do that in a
week is because i've been thinking about
it for years
and at that point i'd learned how to
make an outline and i'd learned how to
you know structure
six acts within a tv show so this is my
first time putting it into a practical
application but because i knew
the steps and i knew what to do i was
able to go ahead and execute it very
quickly
that's not necessarily the case for all
all of the things that i write
but i do find that if you don't have a
good outline to start with
then it's very very very difficult to
tell a compelling story
one that will hold together um and one
that will take you on
the emotional arc that your character
needs to go on
what's been your hardest year here in
los angeles and then what's been your
easiest year
and why well i can say that this year
has been my easiest year
and that's partly because i'm in
the best place i've ever been
emotionally i'm i'm getting married
in a couple weeks congratulations thank
you very much i'm actually
marrying the director of jerumah oh yeah
did this happen
before he was gaston or yeah actually
he didn't get the job because he
probably okay okay all right
no no no that's one way to get a job in
hollywood
no we um we we started dating a few
years ago and you know he's been very
supportive of my work
he himself is a director and a
cinematographer so he understands
uh what it's like to be a professional
in the business um
and he picked up the script to do room
when he read it and just
he really liked it so that's how he got
the job
um but this year has been wonderful i've
you know this
i i have spent the last 20 years
which is how long i've been out here
this is actually my 20th year of being
out here in l.a
um i have it is the culmination
and the the accumulation of every
failure that i've had every success
every person that i've met
this is this is all coming together now
so
it's it's funny that after being at this
business for so long i feel like
i finally am getting a leg up so
i don't want to say that i've ever had
like a particularly a worse
you know a worse year there are
certainly years you know where i've been
you know
financially strapped and i've had to you
know take on
you know extra side gigs to make money
and things like that
all the things that people out here go
through
and deal with um but right now i'm
living my best life
and so you're getting married and
crowdfunding and
maybe shooting a movie or no that's
going to be 20 that'll be 20 20
okay so but you know we just we didn't
want to you know make things too easy on
ourselves by just planning the wedding
so we decided to
do the crowdfunding run after wow yeah
okay
so i'm assuming you're doing the
crowdfunding first and then the no the
wedding and then the crowdfunding oh my
goodness
okay yep that's very ambitious wow
again nobody nobody's gonna do it for
you so
um i can tell you this much we we shot
our proof of concept together last year
and if your relationship can withstand
making a film together
i think you're set up for success i
think you're right i think they say like
travel together and other things i think
it make it make a movie that's that's
number one and make it in the summer
time by the way oh yeah yeah that's
when summer time with no air
conditioning certainly in los
angeles okay
do you like to challenge yourself like
do you like to kind of like accomplish
one thing and go okay i did that i want
to set the bar higher
um i get restless very easily that's not
to say that i get bored with projects
i think for me i'm always sort of
battling these
inner inner demons of you know proving
that i'm good enough or proving that i
belong a certain place i mean again i
didn't
i didn't come from a family with money i
earned my way into usc and i had to work
hard to stay there because i was on
scholarships and grants those those
could be taken away from me at any time
so it's sort of a discipline that i have
given myself i mean if you ask any of my
friends or my colleagues
one of the things that i'm known for is
always having multiple balls in the air
and being a very driven person
[Music]
i i thrive on being active
and busy um i i don't like to
necessarily wait for things to happen
for me i like to try to be the driver of
my own fate
um i mean again it's it's a stone soup
analogy
the more that you put out into the world
the more that you will get back
were you thinking about what your life
would look like when you were driving
cross-country i realized
you were 18 and you were blasting tori
amos oh absolutely you know i wanted i
thought
i thought my my life was gonna be you
know theater
and you know if i was lucky film you
know my my love started in
theater and storytelling i just i
discovered that side of myself
when i was in high school and it's it's
stuck with me
you know you know narrative storytelling
is something that i've just been
i knew that i wanted to do it and i
didn't
know that the thing for me that would
take off would be the writing i had no
idea i had these stories in me
i had no idea that sleepy toes would
become what it was i had no idea that i
would be a children's book author and
i didn't know that the stories that
were the closest to me would be the ones
that would
reach out in the world and
i think it's it's it's a bit of bravery
to
to be able to tell those stories and
open yourself up
but as a writer that's what resonates
with people
so if you can put a bit of yourself on
the page if you can be
you know brave and unsure that and let
people see that
then i think that you're doing yourself
and the world of service
when you were attending usc you said you
had a 40-hour week job
oh yeah so how were you managing that
i'm just curious i didn't sleep
i learned time management skills you
know it's it's you know you asked
earlier about like you know
do you write yeah i write like i i try
to i don't
do it at the same time every day but i
do do it every day a little bit whether
it's jotting out an idea or if it's
fleshing out
you know a pitch or a log line or
something i do something every single
day
so time management i think is is a very
important skill to have as a writer
you know it's it's a good professional
skill to have too you know you never
want to be
late to a meeting you don't want to
waste anybody's time
i feel like um being
being aware of of you know other
people's needs
as well can help serve your own
if a friend were in your shoes what
advice would you give them
change careers okay i'm kidding
um you know i i know
this about myself i get you know i can
get discouraged
and it's sometimes it's very hard to see
the forest
through the trees uh i hope i'm using
that expression correct yeah
yeah i have to do the same thing wait
did i get it right
um but i think you know if it was if it
was a female friend
i think it would be to to find your
tribe and i know that sounds a little
cliche
but it does make a difference you know
you have to find your audience and you
have to find your platform
and the one thing that i would tell any
writer is to
utilize every single experience that you
have ever had and put it in your writing
and put it in your work
i can't tell you the number of times
that you know my
skills as a graphic designer have come
in handy because i've done pitch decks
and i haven't had the money to pay for
anybody to design the pitch deck so i've
done it myself
or i have had to develop characters you
know i i learned asl
as a little girl i've forgotten a lot of
it but i
have you know worked on projects or
gotten meetings or something because of
that particular skill set
so don't discount any experience that
you've had in your life prior to
becoming a writer
that's what makes you interesting that's
what makes you unique that's what makes
you
you know that's what makes people want
to talk to you
so don't discount any experiences that
you've that you've had and see if you
can find a way to put that into your
work